- [Kelly] I like it.
Have y'all, have y'all ever met before?
- [Sam] What's that? No, never.
- No, no.
- Lovely to meet you.
- [Kelly] Well, you did a really
great job of coordinating.
- Yeah.
- You are?
- Did he just say, "Are you English?"
(Kelly and audience laugh)
I love that.
- Actually, no, I don't
wanna embarrass you,
but we did follow each other
on Twitter a few years ago.
- [Kelly] Oh, y'all did?
- Oh, my gosh.
- Um...
- He broke up with you.
- What happened?
(audience and Kelly laugh)
No, what happened?
- I don't think you do anymore.
- No.
- No, do you know what?
We never, we never
actually spoke on Twitter.
- Oh, I think...
- Sorry, this is...
(audience laughs)
- No, I don't go on Twitter.
- Now, it's turned into Jacob
sounding like a stalker.
(Kelly laughs)
- [Jacob] I know.
I was so excited.
I was like, "Sam Smith follows me".
- No way.
I'm so sorry, I'll
follow you on Instagram,
because Twitter, I don't do.
- Okay, cool.
- See, it was somebody else.
- I even dressed in the same color as you.
- I'll DM you.
- Do people still ask you
about "Game of Thrones"
or just annoying people like me?
(Kelly laughs)
- You're not annoying.
Yeah, no, people do still ask.
- Yeah.
- A lot.
- [Kelly] It was such a huge thing.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I mean, I get like a
lot of like, genital questions.
(Sam gasps)
- Like, what questions?
- Because I was a eunuch.
- No, I know, oh, my
God, you said genital.
- [Jacob] Genital.
(Jacob laughs)
- [Kelly] That's what you said.
I thought you said general,
I get a lot of general questions.
I was like, "Like what?"
And I didn't hear
genital, so now I get it.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- I think you're probably fine.
I'm not gonna ask you any
questions about your genitals.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
- Thank you.
- That's amazing.
(Kelly laughs)
I was like, "Well, what
are the general questions?"
I was like, so wait, so
I, I love that though,
because a lot of people don't like when,
like, I don't mind when people
bring up "American Idol".
That's where I'm, I
started in the industry.
I, that's why I don't ever mind,
because it's like, how I got in the door,
where people really got to know me.
- [Jacob] Yeah.
- So, I think it's cool.
Like that's, your first start
is freaking "Game of Thrones".
Even if you're a eunuch
with genital problems.
(audience laughs)
(Jacob laughs)
Is it, is it true though,
you once did a scene
where you had to like speak in Valyrian?
Is that, did you really have to do that?
- [Jacob] Oh, yeah.
Well, I did many, many
scenes in Valyrian, but...
- But I mean like impromptu.
- I know which one you mean, yeah.
(Kelly and audience laugh)
So, I was, I've never had to improvise
in a made up language, not how like...
- Well, nobody has.
- Who among us?
- Yeah.
- But, so there was one night,
it was like a very stressful scene,
everyone's getting ready for a battle.
And it's like pitch black, snow
and the director just
shouts over, he was like,
"Jacob, just improvise something.
Just say something that makes you angry,
but say it in Valyrian".
And I like, panicked and
I just started going,
"Mike Pence, Mike Pence, Mike Pence".
And I shouted, "Mike Pence".
- Oh, my...
- [Jacob] Just over and
over and over again.
- And it wasn't even like political,
you're just yelling it?
Like, you're just like, "Well..."
(audience laughs)
- Maybe a little bit political, but, yeah.
- I mean, what a random thing to say.
(Kelly laughs)
- I didn't know what to do.
- What did the other, did
the other cast members laugh?
- They didn't hear it,
but the director did.
- Oh.
(audience laughs)
- So, when I came back and
I was like, "Was that okay?"
And he was like, "Not
really, no, I can't".
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Not really.
- I can't use that, I was like, "Yeah".
(Kelly laughs)
- So, wait, you're also a musician
and you have several albums.
So, like I love that about
you, what got you into music?
- I think I just, like, I've always,
I grew up in a very musical household.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Like lots of loud music.
- [Kelly] Love.
What kind of genres?
- My dad was really into
like, Dob and Roots,
it was like reggae.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And like, he'd play it at
like, like insane levels.
Like you just feel bass...
- Like, 11.
- Rumbling through you.
- Yes.
- My mom listened to a
lot of house, again bass.
Just all bass.
But I don't make very bassy music,
I make like very sad
music about my feelings.
By the way you, you were,
that was such a beautiful
performance that you just did.
- Oh, thanks.
(audience applauds)
- [Jacob] Loved it.
- I've always wanted to sing with Sam,
you're so good, you're so good, yeah.
(audience applauds)
Well, congrats, like, I
love "Game of Thrones",
but I'm so excited about
"Interview with the Vampire".
Congrats on this, this is awesome.
(audience applauds)
So, is it, does it stick closely
to the movie and like the books?
- Yeah, I mean it's, it's probably,
I'd say it's like a third thing.
So, it's not...
- Yeah.
- It's, it's based on Anne Rice's novels,
but it's, it's based on like
all 18 of Anne Rice's novels.
So, it has like, the,
the movie came out before
she'd written them,
so it could only kind of draw
from "Interview the Vampire".
Whereas this, we just have
like this incredible library
to, to tell stories from.
Yeah.
- Were you always into like, I,
we were literally sitting here going,
"I love vampire stuff".
So, I'm so excited.
Like, were you excited?
Do you like vampire stuff?
- I love vampire stuff.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I love being a vampire,
I've got like teeth.
- [Kelly] Of course, yeah.
- And I always, I've always had,
I've got quite sharp canines...
- I do too, my fangs, I do too.
(audience chuckles)
And they've tried to, they've
tried to saw them down.
Like, once I, I like had braces...
- Who?
- [Kelly] No they try
to, they even them out,
like a lot of kids.
And I was like, "No, no, no, I like them".
- Yeah.
- [Jacob] Yeah...
- It, it made me feel like,
kind of like a vampire,
I like them.
(audience laughs)
- Yeah, you'd freak kids out.
- I'm weird.
- At school, just...
(Jacob hisses)
Just biting people.
Yeah, no, I love, I love vampires,
but I did, there was a movie,
did you ever see "Dracula:
Dead and Loving It"?
- "Dracula Dead"?
- "Dead And Loving It".
- No.
- It was like a Leslie Nielsen comedy.
Like a, like a spoof of vampire movies.
- [Kelly] No.
- And there's just this one scene where,
I dunno if I can say this actually,
but there's this woman that like...
- We'll bleep it.
- Vomits like, I think they were peanuts.
(audience laughs)
Like, peanut shells and
it scarred me for life.
- That sounds like "Witches of Eastwick".
- Oh, my God, I love
"Witches of Eastwick".
- "Witches of Eastwick"?
- Yeah.
Do you know when she's, the cherry pips?
Or is it...
- Yes!
Or something in the, yes.
I love "Witches of Eastwick".
- No, you might have just changed my life,
maybe it was that.
(audience laughs)